i protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using aura i get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so i
can fix the problem fast try aura free
for two weeks using my link below
we have a really packed program today so
i'm gonna do everybody a favor and not
spend five minutes talking about how
it's a packed program and just get into
the substance they're now trying to ban
abortion nationally um i told you this
would happen it wasn't just me it's not
a pat on the back it was very obvious
and many of us were predicting after the
supreme court made a decision which
overturned roe v wade overturning the
fundamental right to an abortion in most
cases for uh but in the united states
we had this prediction that this was
only the beginning now why was it such
an obvious prediction well you don't get
your biggest win and then stop i mean
you know even michael jordan won three
championships before he temporarily
retired and then came back and then won
three more would have been weird to just
win that first one and then say see
everybody later
uh on the one hand there were the sort
of more obvious predictions well once
you overturn the right to an abortion
the next thing is you try to ban it
outright you go beyond just overturning
it as a right you say let's make this
illegal and then beyond that it's maybe
they'll try to overturn the gay marriage
decision from 2015 and on the far end
it's well do they want to try to
overturn interracial marriage much more
far-fetched but the point is you don't
stop after your biggest victory and now
indeed lindsey graham has introduced a
nationwide abortion ban
just weeks after he said well that's
something that should be left up to the
states
lindsey graham is a hypocrite of course
but that's not really what this is about
this is really about the obvious
predictability that this is something
they were going to try to do as rolling
stone writes lindsey graham introduced a
federal abortion ban tuesday weeks after
declaring it's an issue that should be
left to the states i think we should
have a law at the federal level says
lindsay that would say that after 15
weeks no abortion on demand
now on demand is another one of these
propaganda terms what does it mean on
demand it's like you could just add it
to anything well i don't know what what
about uh knee replacement on demand
we're talking about
the exact same process by which you
consult with a doctor and then a
decision is made and a procedure is
either done or not done
at the agreement of the doctor and the
patient on demand is another one of
these phrases that's just meant to make
things seem completely out of control
anyway uh as rolling stone writes graham
wants to overrule the right of states to
set their own abortion laws despite
having said on several occasions it
should actually be decided by states not
the federal government just last month
he said quote i think states should
decide the issue of marriage and states
should decide the issue of abortion so
they're trying to do it
talking points memo article republicans
move to ban
abortion nationwide
and it also this particular article goes
on to talk about the bigger picture
strategy and there is some risk to this
strategy and this is kind of where i
want to focus in because we we knew they
were going to do this and how they're
going to do it is obviously okay it's
all totally predictable
when you look at polling
abortion being legal in most cases is
quite popular with americans in fact
americans are very divided about so many
different issues but abortion being
legal in most cases is one of the issues
on which americans are relatively united
you see significantly more than 60
support
for that and so there's a risk and we'll
see in november whether that risk ends
up damaging republicans there's a risk
that if you focus too much on banning
and preventing abortion that you will
lose support
and that you will lose elections so
there is a political risk here for sure
when you are
loudly running against something that is
popular nationally there's a couple of
possibilities now one possibility and
this is very dark and i hope that this
isn't the case is
if republicans are so sure
that now they've got it successfully
rigged because remember in 2020 they
tried to steal it but they failed
while accusing the left of trying to
steal it which of course the left wasn't
doing
if for 2022 and 2024
they're feeling more confident in their
ability to take elections that the will
of the people doesn't actually show them
winning
then they could say well but we we know
how to win regardless of what people
want so let's go ahead and try to ban
abortion that's one one possibility
the other possibility is that this is a
terrible miscalculation because because
they correctly recognize that being
against abortion is still a great way to
raise money from certain groups but it
has become decoupled from support out in
the general population so they're
interested
they see oh if we if we do this if we
try to ban abortion these money groups
will give us a ton of money but we're
going to lose a lot of the people so it
could be a miscalculation and then the
third one which i don't think there's
really evidence for is they're
intentionally sabotaging themselves
uh
i mean i'm including it in the list but
it doesn't seem particularly likely that
that's what's going on and then the the
fourth possibility also is they just
disagree with the polling
they might just say we don't agree that
two-thirds of americans as every poll
shows believe abortion should be legal
in most cases we think the polling is
wrong and we think this is a winning way
forward now whether they will even get a
vote on this remains a question mitch
mcconnell was asked about it yesterday
didn't really answer
so we're going to continue following it
but not a surprise to anybody who's been
paying attention
after overturning roe v wade the next
step is let's see about a federal ban on
abortion
we'll see where it gets them
i have video for you today
of two guys who are really confident
that
they know a lot of different things and
that they are right
about whatever it is they choose to talk
about i'm talking about bill maher
and nfl quarterback aaron rodgers
now this is a clip from
uh i believe this is bill maher's newish
podcast
and to be very clear
i think aaron rodgers is not a bright
guy and he said a lot of really wacky
things about covid and other things
and i also find his entire world view
completely uninteresting bill maher on
the other hand sometimes does say things
that i find uh prescient and compelling
and accurate but also bill maher
particularly when it comes to medical
stuff like i remember when i was this is
a really long time ago
i remember an episode of bill maher
being interviewed by larry king the late
larry king and bill maher took a
position against aspirin by saying why
would you take aspirin your body is not
in an aspirin deficient state so why
would aspirin ever be the thing to take
which kind of misunderstands
medication completely so he's always
been a little weird on medical stuff
regardless here is a clip of bill maher
and aaron rodgers repeating some of the
most tired lines about
science sometimes is wrong medicine
sometimes is wrong
so therefore you know the covet
conspiracy theorists should have been
listened to just as much as everybody
else let's jump right into this first
clip that's my problem with with society
today is why does everyone have to be so
bipartisan okay now right first of all
aaron rodgers means partisan he doesn't
even know what he's talking about he
doesn't mean why do things have to be
bipartisan he means why do things have
to be partisan
like every issue is not a partisan issue
there's right and there's wrong there's
things that make sense and things that
don't make
sense don't have to
toe the line on what your party's saying
to you know and that's the only stance
you can take right can you not
rationally have a conversation about
things that make sense and be able to to
not be swayed by
whether you vote red or blue not in
america anymore no you can't and and the
ulti to me the ultimate
issue that should not be political or
partisan
is medicine health
yeah what is more personal
than
what i you know you do you to how you
want to uh treat your body now if the
argument is well if you don't do our
pharmaceutical
answer
then you're going to
risk other people's lives first of all
that's not true that's a red herring
argument well sometimes it's true
and sometimes it's not
but it doesn't actually relate to the
bigger issue that they're building to so
this this really is hard to follow
because it's such a mishmash of
different issues there's
whether science becomes partisan and of
course i mean look at what's going on
with climate science one side just
denies the science so you've got that
issue you then have issues of public
health you have issues of bodily
autonomy and they're just mixing
everything together with a big dose of
confidence and what comes out is total
nonsense maybe
that's true with other things at other
times or with this before they knew that
the vaccine
does not prevent infection and does not
prevent transferal so now that we know
it doesn't do either one of those things
it shouldn't matter what i do so again
if you really want to have a nuanced
conversation this is not accurate and
i'm the first to tell you that
there is this very big period in the
sort of meat of the pandemic at which
point the variants that were floating
around in public
were predominantly
not variants that were well handled by
the original vaccines in terms of
infection that's absolutely true
very early on the first when the first
vaccines came out and you still had a
variant out there that was much more
similar to the original variant for
which the vaccines were tailored the
ability to prevent infection was very
high and if you're not infected you
don't have anything to transmit that was
the case early on
as the variance diverged from the
original more and more
the vaccine's ability to prevent
infection and therefore transmission
declined and that's absolutely true
we now have this new vaccine that is
tailored to omicron
and it seems although we still need more
data that the ability of that vaccine to
prevent infection is higher and of
course if you don't have an infection
you don't have anything to transmit so
the overarching broad statements about
this don't really help anybody
but they're determined to moralize about
it and so they have to make such black
and white statements
okay
so
that's first
but beyond that
what could be more personal than how i
choose to treat my body i mean like joke
of it can't play
it's it's so annoying to me i'm watching
the u.s open now yeah last night serena
oh i didn't see she won she lost last
night oh
oh well but the best player in the men's
side can't play
egg and one of the most fit guys in the
world
that's the thing so we've had coveted at
least once if not twice
it's
it is
come to new york is a complete
compendium of what a potemkin village
this whole
arsenal of nonsense they've thrown at
this disease is you know what's even
worse than that though
kyrie irving
attended a basketball game
courtside but couldn't play for his team
right
are you
how is that possible well also he
attended a basketball game
and got to watch it in the stands but
couldn't play on his team because he
wasn't boxed so understand that this is
this is basically outrage porn because
if you sit down you go so what exactly
is the point you're making is the point
you're making that science is sometimes
wrong well science by its nature is a
self-correcting
process and
figuring out where you were wrong is
actually
revered and it's a good thing so that's
not really breaking news is your
argument that corporations don't have
the right legally to require vaccination
because they do and so it's just a
mishmash of stuff it's sort of herschel
walker like in a way more coherent to
just make people mad but it's not
exactly completely clear what they mean
let's just look at one more clip from
this to me the frightening thing was
never the disease itself the frightening
thing was how much you could you could
get people
so quickly to change
their way of life
stay home
wear a mask
you know don't that was altruistic at
first it's like uh yeah yeah take two
weeks
to flatten the curve right
and then
just about well every conspiracy theory
came true vaccine mandates vaccine
passport now understand this is again
more outrage sowing more fear what does
it mean that a conspiracy theory came
true because there were vaccine mandates
we've had vaccine requirements in the
united states going back at least to
1903 out of cambridge massachusetts if
not even be i believe washington's army
right so it
it's not
what does he mean that it's a conspiracy
theory that there were going to be
vaccine mandates
we have all sorts of vaccine
requirements what does that even mean
but people hear it and they go that's
right aaron rodgers is right and i
should be furious right
and it turned into like away from
doing your job to stop the
the spread to like lockdowns and that's
my whole problem
you know by the way remember the the
nobody was locked down in the united
states it's an absurd statement to use
now they'll go well it was effectively a
lockdown because when everything's
closed
most stuff didn't close
there was there was no lockdown i grew
up in a small town with very little
cases up in chico california but all the
small businesses
i mean our favorite restaurants in la
and new york and across the country not
just in big cities
but
some crazy percentage will never open
again yeah and of course that's
absolutely true and i think there are
many criticisms fair criticisms to make
about how covet was handled
there's no problem with that but these
mishmashes of so-called open and
unfettered conversation
they're
obviously these are perfectly fine not
saying anybody should be censored but
they just make people angry without even
knowing what they're angry about and
that is exactly the way that this stuff
works uh remember that on 9 19 monday
morning we'll be doing the next david
pakman show one day membership special
get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com
to be notified of how to sign up
imagine this scenario you try logging
into your email account to see that your
password was changed a few hours ago
except you didn't do it and then you get
notifications of activity from your bank
and from your credit cards but you
didn't do any of it that is what
identity theft is like it can happen
very quickly and if you don't act fast
it can get worse we've dealt with this
at the david pakman show you can find
videos about it and that's why i protect
myself now using aura our sponsor aura
is identity theft protection fraud
monitoring password management and an
antivirus all in one easy to use app
aura will monitor the dark web for your
emails passwords and social security
numbers and will send you alerts quickly
to your phone and email aura also gives
you near real-time alerts on suspicious
credit inquiries like if someone was
opening a loan or a credit card in your
name and if you sign up at aura.com
pacman you will get a free two-week
trial which you can use to see if your
login credentials have been leaked
online
i would want to know that right away use
the link below
all right you knew it was coming today
you knew that today i was going to tell
you that my pillow ceo and founder mike
lindell known to us as pillow the guy
who wants to sue the machines we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines his phone has been seized by
the fbi
at a hardy's drive-through
you really cannot write this stuff this
is unbelievable
uh you play with fire you might end up
getting burned daily beast reports mike
lindell feds seized my cell phone
at hardee's they took my phone the fbi
did
look at this video this is pillow
himself explaining the situation
last night
today the fbi
uh you're going to hear this and you're
probably already hearing in the news the
fbi
came after me and took my phone and
surrounded me at a hardee's
and uh took my phone i run all my
business everything with um
um they could have just what they've
done is weaponized the fbi um
it's disgusting i don't have a computer
everything i do have that phone
everything was on there and uh
um
and they told me not to tell anybody
here's an order not to don't tell
anybody okay i won't
i am
so
yep so there it is mike pillow raided by
the fbi
here he is on the lindell report which
is hosted by someone else
explaining exactly what happened and
again you cannot write this stuff and
pillow's ability to destroy his own
reputation
his own
financial future over nonsense is really
incredible and we go through a hardy's
drive-through
and we pull around the back and we're
just about going through we pulled
through the drive-through to take the
order we pull up and she says pull ahead
you know because they had to make the
order part of it wasn't done we pull
ahead
and a car comes perpendicular and parks
like a little ways in front of us and i
and i've been around the block and i
said to my buddy i said
um that's either a bad guy
or so it's fbi which i guess now is one
and the same for these guys so anyway
as you know uh i have not been to fast
food restaurants in 20 years other than
that emergency starbucks stop a few
weeks ago that i told you about i have
to imagine that even within the fast
food space hardy's is not exactly the
best but i did look it up i found that
hardee's has a hand breaded chicken
biscuit which sounds pretty good but
let's put that aside for now pillow
reportedly worth 300 million dollars at
a hardy's
and gets uh his phone seized by the fbi
now
i think it's important to mention
mike pillow says that this happened
we don't at this point have independent
confirmation that the fbi actually
seized his phone
but let's assume that he is telling the
truth about it and not making the sup
whole cloth and on that basis donald
trump is absolutely furious donald trump
posting to troth central breaking news
mike lindell the pillow guy was just
raided by the fbi we are now officially
living in a weaponized police state
rigged elections and all our country is
a laughing stock all over the world the
majesty of the united states is gone
can't let this happen take back america
and pillow is furious about other things
as well let's talk about that next
not going to spend a ton of time on this
but mike lindell is really starting to
get frustrated that donald trump still
hasn't been reinstated here he is on
this same program where it's his show
the lindell report but he often calls in
as a guest in this case from a car
and he says he's got the the royal flush
and somehow trump still hasn't been
reinstated and he's very frustrated
when you have when i'm sitting on this
kind of evidence we are and that i am
um and you can't it's like having a
royal flush in a poker game but you
can't play your hand i'm tired of it you
know you have a royal flush i want the
game to end and get back to you know get
our country back here let's get this get
this evidence out in the open for the
whole world to see
and uh get rid of yeah um he hasn't
actually shown anyone the evidence in
his post remember last week mike pillow
was posting all over our facebook page
he said that the evidence is as follows
they captured packets from china
they presented everything at the
symposium and china was caught
red-handed not exactly an overwhelming
case here's another one of these
examples from a few days ago lindell
said his cyber guys went through the
data and they found it they found
everything and if you listen closely
you'll probably come away saying they
found what i have really great news um
well call great news um it's four
percent there's only four percent of
those counties so far that cyber guys
have looked at
that are not compromised in other words
96 percent of all the counties we've
went through already which is hundreds
of them have all been machine
manipulated yep and they and this is a
hundred percent evidence so
yeah that's it's evidence as he calls it
also another major declaration from mike
pillow hello i'm mike lindell and due to
your incredible support the original my
slippers are almost completely sold out
okay
so anyway i consider the uh slipper news
basically as important as his claims
there about uh about the evidence this
guy is furious that trump hasn't been
reinstated and it's all absolutely and
completely pathetic and we're going to
watch whether anything actually ever
happens but it seems what's happening
now that his phone has been seized by
the fbi
is the so-called evidence is going to be
evidence in a potential trial against
pillow than evidence that trump should
be reinstated incredible how the tables
have turned a herschel walker our friend
herschel walker was asked about the
economy and his answer was completely
unintelligent uh and unintelligible as
well
now i want to
uh kind of remind you guys of the
context here herschel walker is the
republican senate candidate from georgia
he's running against incumbent
democratic senator rafael warnock
recently walker weighed in on such
issues as 911
foreign policy as well as education and
none of his opinions made any sense and
yet
he is now leading
against rafael warnock most recently
walker appeared on the newsmax show
spicer and company yes with sean spicer
trump's
uh short-lived sort of short-lived press
secretary when he was president and his
answer
doesn't make any sense about the economy
take a listen to this helping spend more
and democrats spend more voting on some
of those bills how are you talking about
this spending and is it a winning issue
in georgia
well it's a winning issue this economy
is a winning issue because i i think
anyone with any types of sense and i i
hate to say that people on the left
don't have sense but you know you don't
spend what you don't have and that
seemed to be what the left has gotten
good at continuing to spend the people's
money and uh this will be good stewards
with people money and they seem to have
to do that and also crime you know
behind that's really going up crime has
really gotten terrible and
you know i'm running against a man that
had called our officers all men and
women in blue thugs and helping so his
view on the economy is
don't spend what you don't have
and crime as well now this guy is
winning this race and that's completely
outrageous but i want to i spotted a
very interesting comment on our
subreddit from user mr waidaban okay
mr
waidaban sort of tried to explain why
walker is doing well in his race
and what mr waidaban said is herschel
walker is expressing
the human mental state after consuming
thousands of hours of right-wing media
and when we hear these word salads from
herschel walker according to this reddit
user
it resonates with this frenzied mental
state of the target audience the people
that are just furious they don't even
know why but they're furious and they're
scared and they're angry
because they've been watching fox news
and newsmax
which is designed to agitate it's
designed to make people agitated and
angry by pressing these buttons and all
you need to do to press the buttons is
to say these things and then if you want
to interpret it that way when herschel
walker goes money we don't have and
crime
it's a crazy thing it's just it's all
over the place it's frenetic
but it's just pushing those buttons of
the very people that it's designed to
and i think that that's a very it's it's
an astute comment quite frankly um
herschel walker also talking about how
he's not doing this for money he's not
running for money who does that remind
you of them when i get to washington i'm
not going to go to washington like
senator why not has done and tried to
double my income you know i've been
blessed through the lord jesus to make
money so i'm not going to washington and
make money yeah sounds a lot like what
donald trump was saying in 2016. i don't
need this i don't i could just hang out
and be fine i'm i don't need the money i
won't even take my salary and we know
how that worked out raping and pillaging
all sorts of institutions and resources
of the united states so when i hear i
don't really need the money from doing
this
to me it only raises red flags because
it's so trumpian if you're listening
today and you want to see these clips in
their full glory we'll have them on our
instagram that's at davidpakmanshow on
instagram
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
today we will be speaking with dr john
abramson who's been on the faculty of
harvard medical school for 25 years and
is author of the new book sickening how
big pharma broke american health care
and how we can repair it are really
great to have you on today and i
appreciate your time
david it's a pleasure to be with you
thanks so you know when we talk about
the modern state of american healthcare
there's many cooks in the kitchen so to
speak and we can talk about insurance
companies we can talk about uh big
pharma we can talk about our political
system and there's all of these
different uh factors
in your book you talk specifically about
big pharma talk to us about why as a
doctor that's where you decided to focus
in this book
right so
i think the biggest
american medicine has enormous problems
our costs are way off the charts the
health of americans is so inferior to
the other wealthy countries that about
480 000 americans die in excess each
year there's trouble all over the place
i think the biggest cause of this
trouble that is unrecognized is the
extent to which the pharmaceutical and
device industries control the knowledge
that doctors rely upon to
formulate their ideas about the best way
to treat their patients
so explain how that leads to
particular
outcomes and disease management which is
often what it is that the doctors are
doing uh quite quite frankly uh how what
is that relationship
so uh let's look at the cancer moonshot
issue which is in the news now with uh
president biden yep um the uh
anti-cancer drugs uh dominate uh
clinical research they're very expensive
uh we could cut
cancer deaths in half in the united
states
by attending to preventive therapies
preventive interventions stop smoking
obesity
environmental risks so what we're doing
because the money's to be made in
developing new drugs and marketing them
what we do is create a body of
of of so-called knowledge that's the
result of research that's commercially
sponsored
that's about drugs
drug therapies for cancer and the uh
preventive side gets virtually no
attention because there's no money to be
made in it what we've got is a a market
failure where the money is invested in
high cost therapies whereas the benefit
could be reaped much more quickly less
expensive more effectively by attending
the preventive approaches so at the
primary care level often an idea is
floated
that you could compensate doctors
not based on the number of things that
are done for lack of a better term but
instead for the sort of successful
management of a patient and actually
keeping them healthy rather than sick
and of course the devil would be in the
details in terms of exactly how you do
it and how you measure and how you
compensate but that's an idea that's
mentioned to put the focus back on
prevention rather than treatment
does that not if you could do that does
that not even really do enough because
what you're describing is so widespread
and established
yeah
it doesn't do enough
it's a good idea i think that paying
primary care docs to take care of people
instead of performing units of work
would be a good idea and i think trying
to minimize the number of procedures
that are done by changing the payment
for those procedures is a good idea and
that would be more effective with
specialists than it would be with
primary care docs so you could capitate
specialists for geographic area and they
would make so much money on salary and
if they did extra say cardiac surgeries
they wouldn't make money
you know if they did extra breast
biopsies they wouldn't make money so
that that's one way to approach it but
the really the core lesion
is that the actual knowledge that
doctors are trained to trust
is
invested in
because it's going to maximize financial
return to the drug companies it's that
knowledge that's the problem and the
idea that those
that that the research projects get
turned into articles in medical journals
that are mostly written by the drug
companies that are peer reviewed but
virtually nobody in health care
understands that peer reviewers don't
have access to the data
and the
guidelines that are written that set the
standards for uh good community practice
and can be produced as evidence in
malpractice cases if you don't follow
them those guideline writers don't have
access to the clinical trial data and
having spent 10 years in litigation i
know that what's in that clinical trial
data the real data is often very
different from the data that ends up in
medical journals so what we've got is
doctors who are compelled to practice
so-called evidence-based medicine which
is means the bottom line two lines of
the abstract in the medical journal and
that's what they said without
understanding that the whole research
enterprises is biased towards making
money that the results aren't peer
reviewed that the guidelines aren't peer
reviewed and what the doctors have been
trained to trust as the information
that's going to best help them take care
of their patients is not trustworthy
there's this example that i haven't read
about admittedly for a little bit so i
hope i get the details mostly right and
i think maybe it's related to exactly
the mechanism you're talking about which
is when it came to cholesterol
there was a point in time and again i
don't know if it was a couple years ago
or more like a decade or 12 years ago
where the sort of a line at which point
one might consider
recommending a statin to a patient was
lowered so basically just the threshold
was changed nothing really changed about
one's likelihood of a cardiac event
nothing nothing really changed other
than instead of saying i don't know if
it was from 210 to 200 or 222 just a
change was made and it was now if the
patient is above this level consider a
statin
i don't know the origins of that change
i don't know if that change was based in
what we might call good good science or
as you talk about
kind of profit driven science or
something else but would that be the
type of thing that is influencing
doctors to make certain decisions that
can be very profitable
that's exactly right and there are two
aspects to that one is there's never
been a study that compared statin
therapy to lifestyle intervention so the
drug companies don't want to do that
study because they can only lose because
they've got they have all the statin
business the other part is that i was
the lead author of an article in the
british medical journal in 2013 which
was
exactly the time that you're talking
about when the standards were changed
and the numbers for cholesterol the the
study results are not transparent docs
don't have them guideline writers don't
have them but there's an organization in
oxford called the cholesterol treatment
trials collaboration that has the data
they made a faustian bargain
with the drug companies that they would
receive their patient-level data and do
meta-analyses on that data and by
combining the statistical power of all
the different
statin drugs uh effects in clinical
trials they would be able to show that
statins work for more people
excuse me
so the ctt
receives the primary data
but the part of their faustian bargain
was they wouldn't release the primary
data so they control what doctors think
they know about these things so i wrote
i was the lead author of this article in
bmj
and we recalculated the ctt's numbers
that they had published in lancet that
justified lowering the threshold for
treating people with cholesterol
lowering medication and we showed that
for people at low risk who don't have
heart disease who have less than 20
percent 10-year risk that there was not
a mortality benefit that
that their data didn't show a mortality
benefit and that you had to treat
between 100 and 140 people for five
years with a statin to prevent one
non-fatal heart attack or stroke so we
wrote that and unfortunately we made a
little mistake in interpreting the
frequency of side effects in a complex
study but it had nothing to do with our
conclusion and the head of the ctt went
absolutely ballistic charged into the
bmj editor's office and demanded
retraction of our article which le
yeah it was an international kerfuffle
it didn't get much uh coverage here in
the united states but it sure got
coverage in europe and it was pretty
stressful
the editor appointed a six-person
panel to
independently evaluate the demand for
retraction the panel voted unanimously
that there was nothing about our article
that
required a deserved or merited uh
retraction and on we went but the ctt
being about a million times more
powerful than me and my three co-authors
had dominated the press the the
headlines so long about this attack on
statins that um we couldn't get our
message across to the public which is
hey if you are a low-risk person you may
want to take statins
but you got to understand it's not going
to improve your longevity
and you have to treat 100 to 140 people
for five years in order for one to avoid
one non-fatal cardiovascular event and
that's your decision it's not you know
i'm not saying yes or no i'm saying
doctors should tell patients that that's
what the situation is and make let the
patients make a decision based on their
own values right
um to talk about something a little more
maybe superficial as it might be within
the the big pharma space no my dad's a
psychiatrist and he will often talk to
me about pharmaceutical reps come to
visit and they bring little footballs
and they bring pens and they bring you
know notepads and all of this sort of
thing and they drop off literature and
sometimes there's invitations to lunch
and sometimes there's other things that
kind of go beyond that
and of course there's this very strange
dynamic where on the one hand
if it were straight up said the idea of
the reps is to encourage the
prescription of medications many people
would say that that's obviously bad the
doctor should simply be deciding on the
merits whether there's a medication
that's appropriate for an individual or
that it isn't and then the
pharmaceutical companies will typically
say that's not why the reps are there
but at the same time if the presence of
these reps
made no difference
it doesn't seem like a worthwhile
expense for the pharmaceutical companies
so there's this kind of weird dynamic
where what are we to interpret to be the
point of these representatives and what
does what do we know about
the impact on the rates of prescriptions
of drugs
when there are verses are not
pharmaceutical reps
well
that's an easy question we know if a
doctor accepts a lunch that is valued at
twenty dollars single lunch that will
significantly change his or her
prescribing patterns
so obviously the drug companies aren't
stupid and they engage in this activity
because it makes the money that makes
them more than it costs them that the
core issue here it makes no sense on the
surface but the core issue is that
doctors in general like to
reciprocate politeness and kindness and
warmth
and they're not in the habit of being
discourteous to people who come saying
they're trying to help them
so the drug reps come and they bring
information some of it is reprints from
journal articles some of it is glossy
charts that are very easy to interpret
but that information is delivered
because of its marketing value not
because of its informational value
because it's that's the information
that's selected that will most likely
convince the doctor to prescribe or
consider prescribing the drug so we've
got a situation where the drug reps are
playing one game they're taught how to
shake hands they're taught how to look
in the eye they're taught how to keep
notes about the kids birthdays and and
their wives anniversaries and they ask
all those questions and the doctors are
trying to get the best information they
can as quickly as they can to best serve
their patients and it's not a fair fight
because the drug reps know that their
job is to increase prescriptions they
get bonus on that they get evaluated on
it they have minders that go out and
watch them perform their
sales spiel
and they get graded on their sales spiel
so it's a situation that exploits
doctors desire to have good information
and
innate
reaction to be polite where politeness
is offered to them the drug reps know
how to exploit the politeness
what's the lowest hanging fruit here if
we were to be able to make
some changes to the way the system works
as you talk about a lot of the
information on which doctors are making
decisions is information controlled by
or created and generated funded by the
pharmaceutical companies all these
different things that we've talked about
we haven't even touched on the direct
advertising of drugs to people via
television which is uh almost completely
unique to the to the united states
what's the lowest hanging fruit that
would give us the most dramatic
improvements
yeah so the lowest hanging fruit is so
low
that it's a stunning commentary on the
power that's controlling american
medicine
when a manuscript is submitted to a
medical journal
usually the company has played a role in
preparing that manuscript and the
manuscript com contains a very brief
summary of the data from that study
the the peer reviewers and the medical
journal editors don't get the data to
see if the manuscript is accurate and
complete but the manufacturers produce
what's called a clinical study report
it's an official document it's often two
or three thousand pages long of
tabulated data that
purports and usually does present the
outcomes that the
researchers said they were going to
study so they can't pick and cherry pick
their outcomes this is a two or three
thousand page document that is prepared
and it's searchable
and the the drug the the medical
journals
they complain that they can't do
transparent peer review because they
don't have the resources to go through
the primary data and get statisticians
to line up the data with the way the
drug company coded and all that and
there's truth to that but this clinical
study report exists it would cost
nothing
nothing for the journals to say
when you submit your article your
manuscript you must submit a clinical
study report if you want to redact a
little bit about how we make the gel
code or whatever you can do that if you
think it's a corporate secret but you
must submit that so why don't the
journals do this obvious thing and uh
and once you learn how to get around the
clinical study reports as i did in
litigation it's pretty quick to figure
out
what's going on why don't they do it
they don't do it because they're in an
enormous conflict of interest position
they make a lot of their money from
selling reprints back to the drug
companies for the
drug reps to hand out to docs like your
dad
so if the new england journal is going
to make uh 900 000
selling reprints of the vioxx article
that misled doctors and had convinced
them that it was safe to prescribe and
didn't increase the risk of
cardiovascular death the the new england
journal wants to have that article
published in its pages and sell 900 000
uh reprints
if they had the clinical study report
they would have known
that the article was um
misleading would be too kind a word but
misleadingly omitted three heart attacks
and didn't present the data on
cardiovascular risk and the new england
journal would have understood that this
was a bad drug it never should have been
on the market and it should have been
withdrawn immediately when the results
of that study came out but the new
england journal won't do it because
they're going to miss their reprint
sales and the lancet and jama and it's
that's the way it works they they miss
their reprint sales their advertising
revenues will go down their impact
factor will go down they won't be the
world recognizes the world's greatest
journal so what's happening is the
prestige much like the prestige of uh
mgh brigham in boston where they mgh
brigham their fabulous world-class
hospitals they spend a fortune on
advertising for their branding and the
journals are in the same business of
maintaining their branding for their
journals and that means that they're
willing to sacrifice the quality
information that doctors get when they
read their journals in order to maintain
the branding factor of the journals
uh eye-opening stuff much of it not the
most uh exciting to read about but it is
important to know what's happening uh
we've been speaking with dr john
abramson who by the way we just lost
your video but we could hear you find
the entire time and it couldn't come as
a better ti at a better time uh since
this is the end of the interview uh yeah
there you are you're back the book is
sickening how big pharma broke american
health care and how we can repair it
we're linking to the book and we really
appreciate your time today
well thanks very much for having me
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpakmanshow all right
let's keep going and get caught up on a
whole bunch of other stuff uh there is a
new filing from donald trump's attorneys
related to the search warrant raid
served on mar-a-lago the documents that
he had in his house etc etc and if you
look through
the legal argument the filing from
donald trump's lawyers they make a
shocking admission in the filing and it
has to do with some quotes quotation
marks are effectively a shocking
admission here
david how is that possible how is it
possible that quotation marks
are a shocking admission well the use of
these quotation marks exposed the level
of desperation
that these lawyers are now exhibiting
and it has to do with quotation marks
around the word classified
in a number of spots in this legal
filing trump's lawyers put quotes around
the word classified when talking about
classified documents
and they decry in the filing that the
government has unilaterally determined
that these are so-called classified
documents
think about that
think about the level of desperation
that you have reached
when you're legal filing
attacks the fact
that the government and the government
alone has determined documents are
classified and you call that
classification into question with
quotation marks
who else determines the classification
of documents who else gets to decide
and when you are experiencing it's one
of two
such brain rot
or such desperation that in order to
assemble what is an attempted defense of
your client's actions
you have to put in quotes the word
classified and act as though it's
illegitimate or wrong that yeah the
government deter when we talk about
classified documents
we're talking about the government what
you does apple get to decide what are
classified documents no corporations can
have trade secrets sure
but of course it's the government that
has decided what is a classified
document and here the entire legal
filing is based around the idea and i'm
not going to spend a lot of time on this
it's just to kind of let you know where
things stand
the legal filing is based on the idea
of trivializing classified information
now remember at first it was the fbi
planted the stuff this wasn't even stuff
trump had and then it was well trump had
declassified all of the stuff and then
of course that fell apart because it
just doesn't work that way even william
barr trump's own former attorney general
said you can't just go declassified and
everything's declassified it doesn't
work that way
then we determined that in fact the
classification status of many of these
documents is not relevant to the
statutes under which donald trump is
being investigated but put that aside
they don't seem to care about that now
they've moved on
to trivializing the concept of something
being classified
and whether the classifier is legitimate
when the classifier is obviously the
government this is obviously chaos all
created by donald trump's actions
but they are adding to the chaos trump's
lawyers added to the chaos by requesting
a special master and then now they're
telling the judge you got to stop this
chaos well this is chaos of your own
creation these are absolutely and
completely total clowns by the the word
that should be in quotes is lawyers
not classified and we'll see whether
this works out or whether it goes
anywhere going to another court case
that we're following
the second alex jones defamation trial
has now started
there's a great article on reuters which
we are linking to it's an explainer
what's at stake in alex jones second
sandy hook defamation trial now we
interviewed plaintiff's attorney mark
bankston a few weeks ago who
already obtained a nearly 50 million
dollar judgment against jones in the
first defamation case and now is
representing plaintiffs in the second
case as well very important uh items
here about this case this is the
connecticut case as it's being called
it started this week
13 family members of sandy hook victims
as well as one fbi agent are seeking
damages from jones and free speech
systems for claiming they were so-called
crisis actors lying about their
relatives death
as part of a gun-grabbing conspiracy by
the united states that's what donald
trump donald trump that's what alex
jones claimed initially about sandy hook
that's what this is about okay
then we get to
the next uh trial which started
yesterday and in yesterday's trial
alex jones
new attorney
did an impression of alex jones himself
now i am not a legal scholar i am not a
legal expert i don't know
that this early in the trial doing an
impression of your own client
shows that you're heading in a good
direction maybe later in the trial the
impressions are appropriate check out
this wacky video you'll see a video
shot each one of them yeah that's right
when i go out on the street people
forget adam lanza was the killer they
think it's me
they've made escape
the lawyer
in doing an impression of jones
seems to be using that video where alex
jones goes nuts
to show how much of a victim
jones actually is here now of course
what his lawyer was referencing was this
completely insane interview that jones
gave andrew callahan a couple weeks ago
remember this do you feel responsible
for what happened to the sandy hook
families yes i killed the children
but beyond that no i mean i went in that
school i pulled a gun out i shot every
one of them myself i mean i'm i'm i'm
guilty it's true no but i don't know
let's just
do i feel responsible that someone
on on that played
video games on a bunch of drugs went and
killed a bunch of kids and then the
internet questioned it and i covered
that no i don't feel responsible and i
don't apologize anymore i'm done
i don't apologize i killed the kids
was there a definitive no i killed him i
killed him all right anyway so that's
what was being referenced there so the
trial clearly not off to a good start
and then here's another moment from the
first day of the trial i believe this
was the first day judge barbara bellis
sanctions jones because yeah he refused
to participate in discovery this was an
issue in the first trial and it was an
issue in the second trial and here is
the judge saying
you're not participating in discovery
i'll make the following observation
this stunningly cavalier attitude with
respect to
their discovery obligations is what led
to the default in the first place
the defendants have consistently engaged
in dilatory and obstructive discovery
practices true from the inception of
these cases
right through to the trial and finally i
will note there is there is no notice
in this file
to this minute of any
supplemental compliance producing the
google analytic documents which is
required by the practice book but was
also required by my clear court order of
september 30 2021 which apparently was
not followed here so the motion is
denied
for these reasons and the
court hereby sanctions the defendants by
precluding them
from presenting evidence or argument
that they did not profit from the sandy
hook coverage
there you go uh judge barbara bellis uh
not not pleased with what it's going is
going on so listen in all likelihood
this will be another disaster for alex
jones
but we're not going to prejudge it it's
just the most likely outcome we're going
to follow the case
hey uh this is amazing lauren beauberg
radical and repugnant republican
congresswoman lauren beaubert apparently
in her desire to complete compete with
marjorie trader green
is now going after wonton killing
i know i i'm saying that correctly in
the sense of this is how she said it
preaching from a bible verse lauren
bobert
didn't understand
the word wanton
and instead
attacked wonton killing
taking a very forceful stand against
chinese dumplings and then
all hell broke loose
rampant evil grabbing and grasping
vicious backstabbing
they made life hell on earth with their
envy wonton killing i don't know what a
wonton killing is
i'm gonna have to look that one up
[Laughter]
it is hard to think of a woman more dim
sum i'm sorry
a woman more dim than lauren beaubert is
what i mean
this is actually the thing trump does
trump does this thing where he reads the
speeches that someone else wrote for him
and he reacts to them like he's reading
a news article trump will say during a
speech
and it is once again democrats who a
dozen times have acted to try to get us
banned from twitter that's true that's
actually true well didn't know that but
that's true he'll re he's doing a
commentary on the speech which makes it
very hard to believe that it's actually
his words it's the exact same thing with
lauren bobert
wonton killing there's by the way
you know how i talk about this theme of
these right wingers who are incredibly
confident
about things they're completely wrong
about here's lauren bobert explaining to
others
the right way to say
our inalienable with certain inalienable
rights that's inalienable that word is
not pronounced inalienable
these rights are
unalienable um they are
that's a very very important declaration
so there's lauren beaubert these people
continuing to be visibly confused at the
things that someone puts in front of
them to write
and uh it is quite a doozy quite a doozy
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here is a caller
who is telling me i'm wrong
donald trump didn't get arrested now you
might be saying david when did you say
trump got arrested and of course the
answer is never listen to the confusion
here
hey david it's frank from florida yeah
i'm watching your segment on uh
wondering if trump
uh got arrested yeah there's no way in
the world that that happened okay and
him being quiet about it okay he'd be
screaming
holy hell
um so i doubt very much that's what
happened yeah i never said that trump
got arrested so the story monday was
trump's suddenly in dc
unannounced trip he's just there
and there's speculation as to why
is he in dc because he's going to get
arrested he's been told you have to turn
yourself in
is he in dc because he is just plain go
so i never said
maybe trump got arrested and nobody
heard about it of course if trump had
gotten arrested we would have heard
about it the speculation was has he come
to dc because he has been told by law
enforcement he has to surrender
and that's not what it was but
it wasn't the claim that i made so i'm
glad to get the opportunity to clarify
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today it's it really speaking of alex
jones this is a bonus show that's going
to throw him off his rocker oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves as bad this one's really
going to send him for a loop
ken starr the prosecutor of the clinton
whitewater investigation has died at age
76 this is one of the earliest political
memories i have the the this
investigation done by ken starr we're
going to talk about it on the bonus show
alabama
may start using nitrogen hypoxia for
executions for a death sentence as
executions for people on death row what
is it
and does this present new legal problems
as alabama has been plagued by issues
when it comes to executions and we are
going to talk about the broader based
inflation that we have been seeing
recently uh where is it what sectors and
what are the implications all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
you can get instant access by signing up
at joinpacman.com
we are also now only five days away from
our one day
blowout membership special monday
morning 9 19 we are doing a 9 19
themed membership discount
to try to do a record one day membership
drive bigger than we've ever done before
let's hope
if you want to be notified hey
sir or ma'am
here's the coupon code
take advantage of it you need only sign
up for my newsletter at
davidpakman.com and then monday 9 19
you will get that beautiful and clear
email with instructions on how to do it
so for our current members we will see
you on the bonus show for our future
members look forward to welcoming you on
monday
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors i protect all of
my passwords accounts and devices using
aura i get instant alerts about threats
like if my email or password are found
on the dark web so i can fix the problem
fast try aura free for two weeks
using my link below